good evening welcome my name is
Christine rat I work in the School of
the Arts we've been working on the
Midnight's Children project and I'd like
to introduce to you Imam Talib abdur
rashid and professor omnia al-islam and
they are here to talk about the Muslim
perspectives on Midnight's Children we
may have a couple other speakers arrived
but we'd like to get started now so I
without further ado I give you Imam to
leave abdur rashid and professor Emir of
Islam actually this is Professor Ghazi
oh I'm sorry for the promotion thank you
well good evening everyone peace be on
to walk so I'm what equal seems one of
the most important readings that we can
be giving each other right now is the
greetings of peace they are in a
troubled world the tonight's discussion
programs last discussion as I'm sure all
of you realize was precipitated by the
coming to Harlem coming to New York City
and coming to Harlem of the plane
Midnight's Children based upon some wish
by the same name when those of us in the
Muslim community became aware that the
play was heading this way we were
contacted by people from Columbia
University they were very nice over at
the School of the Arts and they were
concerned about community reaction to
wish these play coming and it turned out
to be a legitimate concern so when we
had dialogue with the Dean of the School
of the Arts and later with columbia
university president Bollinger and then
the people at the Apollo we realized
that a good way to approach the coming
of the play would be to frame it within
the context of discussion we had a very
lively forum this past Friday morning
over at the Apollo Theater that was
attended by several members of the Royal
Shakespeare Company people from the
community of african-american cultural
institutions etc so in discussing
Midnight's Children we thought that a
forum like this would be a good idea so
that we who are members of the Muslim
community could express to you what some
of our concerns are and have been
regarding of mr. Bush these of
not so much this one particular word but
actually going all the way back to
satanic verses which really helped to
Porsche mr. Bush the outer to the
general public eye and one of the things
that we felt very strongly about all
along is that much of the Muslim world
found mr. wish peace walk Satanic Verses
so offensive and responded to it at such
a visceral manner that we believe it
created a kind of negative publicity
that caused people to respond more to
issues of you know freedom of speech and
the Khomeini fatwa and that kind of
thing and to overlook the legitimate
sentiments of those of us in the Muslim
community so having said that I'm going
to ask brother ghazi khan khan who is
the executive director of the Council on
american-islamic relations in New York
branch as a matter of fact their
headquarters is right across the street
really over in 475 Riverside Drive in
what they call the
box and relic Ozzy is also the
interfaith director of the islamic
center of montana so he is going to kind
of start us off this evening by
addressing the subject of the initial
offense the offensive imagery toward the
sacred persons of islam that occurred in
which these work and what we believe to
be a door that was opened up that is
still open right at this very moment so
let's welcome Peleg ashikaga bismillah
r-rahman r-rahim and the name of god
most gracious most merciful as you know
Muslims bear witness that there is only
one God that Prophet Muhammad is the
last messenger that Prophet Abraham was
her even lost a friend of God that Moses
was Karim Allah with whom God spoke
directly and that Jesus son of the
virgin mary by the will of God is mean
ruhila that is from the Spirit of God
having said this
we have
recently been faced with an assault on
al-islam three faiths of more than 1.2
billion human beings in the world seven
million of whom are American Muslims the
assault came from people such as none
but mr. john ashcroft whose head in a
an interview that Islam is a religion
which God requires you to send your son
to die for him and then he compared to
Christianity where he said God sent his
son to die for you to make a comparison
of course very unrepresentative of a
person of his stature to say that Islam
is a region which God requires you to
send your son to die for him but that is
a very wrong interpretation in fact it
is
I'm sorry that he said it we wrote to
him to see if he would respond no
response other assaults came from
televangelists such as pat robertson who
has a daily defamation of an Islam and
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
another gentleman by the name of Jerry
vines in a speech to the Southern
Baptist Convention we describe Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him as a quote
unquote demen possessed pedophile
Franklin gray have the son of the famous
Billy Graham Reverend brilliant there to
claim that al-islam court is a very evil
and wicked religion
another source the free Congress
foundations William Lind alleged and
said that there is no such thing as
peaceful Islam court it syndicated
columnist by the name of Ann Coulter's
call to invade Muslim countries and
convert the population to Christianity
Concorde another one is a sarcastic
suggestion by an editor of the National
Review which said that new king Mecca
our holy city would send a signal to
Muslims fox news bill o'reilly compared
our holy book al-quran to mine come
former Special Counsel of President
Nixon Chuck Colson's claimed that Islam
is a religion which breeds hatred and so
on and so forth I was wondering where
did this originate how
good people
go solo in describing the peaceful
religion of Islam and its prophet
muhammad peace be upon him some of you
might know some others might not know
that we as Muslims believe in all of
God's prophets from adam to know I to
Abraham to Ishmael Isaac to Solomon to
David to Joseph to Moses Jesus and
Mohammed whenever we mentioned their
names we must say peace be upon him the
same thing with the Virgin Mary so peace
be upon her but these are personalities
that God Almighty has chosen and so who
are we not to reveal what God had told
and then I remember that few years back
a man by the name of Salman Rushdie
wrote a novel and call it The Satanic
Verses and I remember the uproar which
resulted
after that publication and the media
unfortunately stereotyped Muslim
protests as anti-intellectual and
against freedom of expression and
Muslims we know that we uphold freedom
of expression but want these freedoms
exercised with responsibility respecting
other people's sense sentiments and
human rights as well reading that the
Satanic Verses reading it was really a
traumatic experience for any believing
Muslim or even for a sensitive and
decent human being quoting the unquote
Abel was a very difficult task so let me
take you back to those days and look at
where he began and where he is now
you know in this age of enlightenment
and information as a matter of profound
regret that al islam is one of the most
misunderstood religion and its Prophet
peace be upon you among the most
maligned persons in the West there has
been a positive shift of in developing a
better understanding of al-islam in
Western academia and among the public
Salman Rushdie's Satanic Verses
published and will publicize by in the
west by foul powerful publisher Viking
and penguin took several steps backward
in this regard it added new strengths to
the woeful ignorance and prejudice
against al-islam in the West never in
the long history of the West and tagging
ISM of to Islam have Islamic beliefs and
its profits being so mocked and maligned
as in Rushdie's and vikings joint effort
furthermore for the first time the
prophets revered family and companions
were made targets of obscenity and
ridicule
the theme of the novel The Satanic
Verses is really not a simple a novel
one encounters a dizzying variety of
meanings within each situation there are
stories within stories they are history
grading as dream the novel deals
primarily with two Indians by the one
his name debris or Gabriel and the other
one is solid into skeleton both foils to
one another these names not only
represent two persons but like other
names in Rusty's novel have great
symbolic significance Gabriel invokes of
course angel Gabriel who was entrusted
with the task of bringing god's final
revelation alcohol and cream the holy
book to prophet muhammad peace be upon
him it is through Gabriel or Gabriel
that rigidly lets loose his imagination
and launches attacks against al-islam
and its most revered personalities
two of his dreams Archer and the parting
of the Arabian Sea deal with a
superstitious charismatic woman Aisha
the name state of Prophet Muhammad's
young wife is not a coincidence in
Rushton's who leads a believing crowd to
Mecca through the sea and drown them the
phenomenon reminds us of cults in
America remember the year Jim Jones in
Jamestown it is not uniquely Muslim but
rigidly must have a purpose in
describing it this superstitious
attitude is definitely neither rational
noor islamic to other dreams muhammd and
return to Julia a deal with the life of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him in
makkah and his return from el modena to
conquer Makka are most objectionable and
anti-islamic
our concerns as Muslims
was not with the literary value of the
novel but rather with Rushdie's
treatment of al-islam we as Muslims
recognized Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him is a historical person and the
religion and Islam is a historical
phenomena a worthy subject for any
historians attention Muslims have and
can respond to scholarly criticism of
that Islam but we do not indulge in
vulgarity against others and do not
relish vulgar attacks on our faith and
revered personalities of alyssa the Arab
Society at that time safeguarded not
only the verbatim revelation of al-quran
whose protection we believe is promised
by God or Allah subhana Allah without an
iota change but it also
preserved preserved details of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him his life and
message we ourselves have been erudite
critics of the arrest and variegated
tradition and are ready to discuss a
serious criticism from any source but if
Rosalie and Viking had chosen to attack
on its lab from a historical perspective
there would be no occasion of Muslim
protest we could expect a reasoned
rejoinder from Muslim scholars who felt
it necessary Bruce Lee inviting however
chose to ridicule the Prophet his family
and companions by inserting
misinformation imposing false motives
creating false history and drawing and
leading the reader to sickening
conclusions
and it is these issues that we did
address and we would like to mention
some of them tonight before I point out
the anti-islamic attacks of froosh
League we want to state the Islamic
position with regard to the
personalities and belief system attached
and that were attacked and ridiculed in
the roshni novel our objection is not to
the central theme of the book whatever
may be its scholarly merit but to the
two chapters called mohand and returned
to jay aaliyah depicting Gabriel's dream
scenes which purport to present the
Prophet his companions his family and
Islamic features the Islamic position on
those topics for us as Muslims Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him is the last
and final messenger of god in line with
Abraham Adam Moses and Jesus and the
others are mentioned earlier
this brings to perfection the teachings
of the former prophets Prophet Muhammad
is a model and perfect human being
possessing a most beautiful pattern of
life and he must be followed by Muslims
in every detail of our lives we love him
more than our own lives and anything
else we hold dear
the wives of the Prophet are called the
mothers of the believers and the best
models of piety nobility and generosity
to be followed by all men and women we
received much of their knowledge of
Islam and of the life of the Prophet
through them the Companions of the
Prophet are exemplary human beings whose
morals manners and style of life were
patterned after the prophets their
greatness comes from their closeness and
dedication to the Prophet they learned
Islam directly from him and taught it to
the next generation in a most authentic
manner
the Prophet peace be upon him his family
and his companions are respected loved
and followed by all Muslims they speak
on the rific words when mentioning their
revered names and invoked God's mercy
and blessings upon them the holy book al
Quran is the final perfect and verbatim
revelation from God Almighty to Prophet
Muhammad through the angel Gabriel and
the angel Gabriel was especially
assigned by God to bring revelation to
all the prophets of God
and the final revelation of alpha and to
Prophet Muhammad neither angel Gabriel
nor Prophet Muhammad added subtracted
omitted or missed any portion of this
revelation of alcohol and cream that
would be a sinful act in my stomach law
the text of alkyl n and its message is
protected and we'll be safe guard
forever by God Almighty as promised in
al-quran when we read indeed we have
revealed this remembrance which is up
for an and we shall for sure safeguarded
that is a for an extent
Alice time is not a new religion but a
path revealed to mankind through many
prophets from Adam to Jesus peace be
upon them and Islam means submission to
the will of God and to live at peace
with all of God's creation
these Muslim beliefs are sacra sent to
us and Muslims are well known for taking
their beliefs very seriously
our response were responses were as
follows first we wrote to the publisher
about our objection and saw them to
withdraw the book but received a
stubborn negative response Vikings that
only decided to publish the book but i
plan to translate it into many other
languages many other responsible muslim
groups sort an interview with the
publishers to explain to them our point
of view we will turn down many muslim
groups met separately to discuss the
book and all of them emphasized
moderation and patience by and large an
enraged and insulted muslim community
has heeded their call the Western press
however has reported these most
disciplined protests as threats to the
freedom of the press we're even Islam
its profits and it's revealed
personalities were never so blatantly
ridiculed as in this book and we urge
all people of good faith to support our
position the issue for the Muslims is
not a freedom versus control but of
decency versus obscenity
and human understanding versus slander
we believe that all personalities and
beliefs are open for discussion and
dialogue but in expressing our opinions
we should not ridicule and debase others
faith or leaders our argument must not
come from dreams or imaginations but
from the facts of history and recognized
sources we support freedom of conscience
and uphold the rights of free expression
but believe such rights must be
exercised with responsibility helping to
build mutual understanding and should
not be expressed to hurt ridicule or
slander anyone such negative actions
belonging to the dark ages and we should
not turn back the wheel of history to
flink ourselves into the age of
ignorance prejudice and bigotry human
society needs a breath of fresh air
we also urged muslims to show the same
rigor for supporting individuals and
institutions which promote islamic
teachings at the same time to write
other books so as to compete with such
versus choice of the name by the way of
the book The Satanic Verses and
principal characters like my hound for
the name of Muhammad peace be upon him
clearly show his intention to slender
Islam and hurt Muslims what relevance
does the title The Satanic Verses have
to the basic story of the novel
orientalists resurrected it to make a
point what is that point that there was
a story that these with an incident
reported by a man by the name of October
e and e bin saud regarded as weak
sources by Muslims the incident is not
reported by other reliable sources and
both classical and modern writers have
critically examined the evidence and
rejected the story but Orientalist as I
said resurrected to make a point the
possibility of satanic interference with
the revelation of a crime thus
questioning for an equal Santa seat
Rasheeda only uses the supposed incident
as an argument against or any
concentricity but by making it the title
of his novel popularizers an
unauthenticated incident not relevant to
the theme of the novel reveals more the
mind of its author than the subject
itself first he makes his purpose clear
by another of his choices instead of
Mohammed he chooses my hound a worsen
medieval Christian substitute for the
word Mohammed or she knows the reason
and explains candidly and says here he
is neither muhammad nor Maui Hammond has
adopted instead the demen tab the
Frenzy's hung around his neck to turn
insults into strength wigs Tories and
blacks all chose to wear with pride the
names they were given in scorn likewise
our mountain climbing profit-motivated
solitary is to be the medieval baby
frightener the devil's seen on him
Muhammad
signifying his choice Rose Lee does not
mince words Mohammed for him is the
medieval baby frightener the devil's
synonym muhammd both choices are
intentional and point to the purpose of
disparaging al-islam and hurting Muslim
sentiments but it is good business and
the Western media would relish any such
thing the two chapters containing the
dream scenes of Gabriel mohand in return
of jalea are well connected and deal
chronologically with the prophets life
in Mecca and Medina respectively Rushdie
uses the dream to rewrite his own
history of Islam rugeley or any human
being for that matter knew very well the
responses of the Muslims Rushdie's
obscene language describing the pious
Muslim personalities cannot be justified
or excused Muslims not only respect
Prophet Muhammad and his pious followers
but also respect other religious
teachers even though they may not
believe in them Ashley relished using
insulting and profane language he puts
words into the mouth of his characters
to ridicule revered Muslim figures to
cite a few
the three companions of the Prophet
began harlot and salman are called
stupid drunk the trinity of scum that
bunch of riffraff excuse my language
clowns that's language of roshni
and he used that term 52 times in that
scholarly knob 52 times using that F
word in many different forms Prophet
Abraham peace be upon him is called
bastard salman stinks of alcohol the
worst target of his ridicule is Prophet
Muhammad himself prophet Oh Mohamed is
brought to him tent one of the ladies of
Mecca in an unconscious state he asks
hint how he happens to be there and hint
answers court I was walking in the city
streets last night masked to see the
festivities and what should I stumbled
over but your unconscious body like a
drunk in the gutter muhammd I sent my
servants for a litter and they brought
you here uncle
obscenity and pornography are
unfortunately becoming accepted literary
forms nowadays it seems the media
portraying intimate scenes on Prime TV
has become acceptable and may even bring
higher ratings Bruce Lee takes it a step
further and shows the prophet and his
pies family than the most vulgar scenes
the profit lies naked and unconscious in
the tent of hint with a splitting
headache these are quotations hint
offers him a silken robe which has a
convenient opening for in fingers to
penetrate and stroke his chest she tries
to feel him to feed him sorry melon
cubes with her fingers hand in a
sensuous scene after the conquest of
Mecca is shown licking the prophets feet
in excessive sensuous adoration the
prophet wrestles with Gabriel the angel
in the cave stark naked with a vivid and
intimate descriptions
the prophets wives are paraded in a
brothel
so many things that really really hurt
us very very much an in conclusion i
might say whatever may be the various
merits of the RISD novel The Satanic
Verses we are deeply hurt and profoundly
shocked to read in this novel the most
unreadable caricatures of the revered
personalities we hold in the highest
esteem the novel describes Islamic
personalities in the most vulgar
language it characterizes the Prophet
his companions his family and his faith
in the worst obscene language it insults
the mothers of believers by portraying
their namesakes and shameless scenes in
the brothel it ridicules and distorts
islamic beliefs and describes them in
profane language it distorts historical
facts and invents deliberate lies which
show al islam its profit in the worst
light the publication of such literature
if it is literature is an insult to
human dignity decency and good taste
it strengthens prejudice increases
ignorance and makes the existing gap
between various communities wider and
wider we believe that while a lively
debate is possible on doctrinal
differences vulgar attacks on any
society's revered personalities its
sacred literature and religious beliefs
must be banned we demand is not against
freedom of expression but it is to
emphasize responsibility which must
accompany such freedom a responsibility
for decency fairness justice and
compassion
Muslims of the world must appeal to all
people of faith to systematically
understand our deep grief and seriously
consider our objections for such
so-called novels and literature
I had to go into some detail so that we
can come to understand the present
situation which I hope my brother will
present you thank you for your patience
thank you brother ghazi khan khan i
wanted to just mention that the council
on american-islamic relations or care as
they are known in the community they
were one of the major groups that was
involved in this whole struggle around
us a tonic versus contacting the book
companies trying to set up the meetings
and all of the things that build a gauzy
and mentioned also the think if we
perhaps at another time that our next
presenter is going to address some of
the other related issues but this is
actually a we actually can make is a
very broad panel and talk about
desecration of sacred persons from all
the various faiths traditions the over
the years there's been a great deal of
opera war around films like The Last
Temptation of Christ reserve sports AC
movie it was caused a scene and just
about a month ago there were several
demonstrations out in San Francisco
because one of the
movie theaters have been advertising
that they were they were about to show a
screen a pornographic film entitled sex
life of Muhammad and it was only because
there was this tremendous uproar that
made yellow back away from it I imagine
that eventually it probably out it up in
a video the one other thing before i
introduce a professor al-islam we
actually had hoped to be joined by two
more panelists who are representatives
of the southern Asian community and
because we really wanted to demonstrate
to you that this sense of offense and
objection that we find in the Muslim
community that has nothing to do with
ethnicity so in just in thinking about
the program so yeah we get Arabs African
Americans southern Asia but then
unfortunately I received phone calls
from both of them at the last moment
having to bow out of 11 of them sister
Robin ania's is an activist at the
southern Asian community here
particularly active in under with women
who are victims of domestic violence and
that kind of thing umbrella Tareq right
man from the Islamic circle of north
america got called out of town on a
family emergency pensa i did want to
share that with you our next speaker is
professor amir al islam professor
al-islam is a teacher of islamic and
african african american studies at mega
evers college over and I want to say the
borrow a book of Brooklyn sometimes I
want to call it the other countries of
Brooklyn on the other side of the bridge
professor al-islam is also a well-known
and respected worker in interfaith
relations dear has done a lot of work
with United Nations connecting NGOs the
World Council of religious and peace etc
and he is a member of the executive
committee of the Muslim alliance in both
America and so now we're here from
Professor I'm me all Islam thank you
very much testing
this much superstition if your mouth sit
yo man
but I need to hold the mic and move my
college dramatized conversation so to
speak ok I will begin with the phrases I
would first like to just thank you for
coming I think it's important that we
begin to begin and continue discourse
around issues that are that we are
confronted with her this a very
challenging time that we live in I
thought about last night i was at a
mosque less that i gave a talk and i
began with a sentiment i was sitting
when the restaurants
the night that our president had given
Saddam Hussein not to meet him to leave
but he'd o'clock p.m. I was sitting in a
restaurant and I was uh it was lightning
outside Thunder rain it I thought about
the flash of the light and I thought
about the reality of the children who
went back there who would be and
continue to be traumatized by the
bombing and the destruction was going on
in Damascus meaning infected
and I thought about the fact that how
would one explain to the children when
will we be able to start the healing
process that would allow us to embrace
one another and accentuate those higher
ideals that we all in religion say that
we represent and it said tremendously to
think about but then has I guess Hobbs
on the reckless westerville haces would
say that I'm to following their receipt
alien I'm following too much of the of
Aristotle's idealism and not enough with
Makaveli we ilysm because human beings
do kill each other em killed each other
and will continue to problem two kill
each other but that however does not
stop me from working very diligently to
change that existential reality that
said you so much I'm not going to
present paper to you I just want to have
a conversation with you
I my my brother Gaza can they gave you
the idea what delineated the issues
surrounding salmon rushdie and this
issue of The Satanic Verses I think you
have an indication of what it meant to
Muslims it hurt us deeply
it's been hurtful pain
but as you know in 1997 rusty kind of
North apology and in good faith however
unfortunately the amount
or the fatwa continued and I think was
raised eight hundred thousand dollars so
unfortunately they didn't forgive him
for reaching out and make an apology i
would like for them to forgive him
because I think forgiveness is such
indica is such an indication of the
spirit of the Prophet Muhammad so long
in the Senate who was our prophet in our
messenger that he was always
compassionate and understanding and was
always ready to forgive because he had
an understanding and a desire that if we
won't walk into paradise he had this
idea that all human beings had value
this is part of a prophetic message that
all human beings were sacred whether
they were Muslims or not but all human
beings has an innate value that he
cherished and he went to help all of
them so Islam for me
accentuated my sense of humanity the
humanity that I got in Christianity
before most part of any minute so Islam
sharpened it focused it building upon
what was there what I would like to say
about Salman Rushdie is the issue of
aside from this the venomous vitriolic
attacked attack against Islam and
Muslims as you know many of us who are
in the university or in college
particularly we talk about modern
postmodern literature language analysis
I would be afraid to think of what
derrida would do to the canons of Islam
or the Koran see the post structureless
and the deconstruction is are looking to
destroy to under matta to unravel
absolutes so at its highest level as
every segment with advisors the
intellectual role of intellectuals the
question those absolutes to make us room
to make us evaluate to make us really
value eight because those truths are not
always seamless but unfortunately he
moved beyond a rational critique
analysis
into a venomous attack and in this world
we really don't have much place for that
I didn't support the idea of the death
on his life I don't support it now it's
my own particular personal physician
perspective and I think he's learned
something from that experience I hope he
has but what I want to talk to you about
very briefly is something that is more
symptomatic of Salman Rushdie's project
that is indicative of I think what I
would like to just share with you today
and that is the way that he looks at
this world the way that he is positioned
in the nexus of what he calls the
Western world and the world of Islam and
that nexus is troublesome
and he comes out on the side of
recognizing valor izing celebrating the
wonders of the Western world and he
demonizes and Dina great sin
marginalizes the world of Islam the
world in which he was a member of and
I'm sure somewhere within his heart of
hearts much of the bitterness emerged
and as he talks about and his indicative
of his new play he was troubled when
there was a petition in India and
Pakistan when he had to leave and I'm
sure in his heart of hearts that had
something to do with his I can only call
it hatred secondly it probably has
something to do with his conceptual in
conceptualization of Islam represented
by those that often misrepresented shlom
and that is Muslims because one must
always make a distinction between the
high lofty ideals of what islam teaches
and the humble mistakes and the
imperfections of human beings who are
striving to reach that ideal because
that ideal is there it is beautiful it
is perfect but we are so imperfect and
trying to reach it so to me his project
Brett represented
a perception that I'm sure many of you
share in a violent or anything else
tonight what are my agenda is is that I
want you to leave this room thinking all
I may do it subtly that the great
civilization of Islam the one point four
five six or seven billion people in this
world that adhere that practice is
religion have some redeeming features
and they have something to offer to this
great western civilization that we see
him and we live in and we relish in
every cherishing that we celebrate if I
would have done that I would have
converted you not to Islam but to an
appreciation but why so many people know
this way a lot and I can only do that by
bringing breaking down the barriers of
misconceptions and misunderstandings
that are inherent in the literature that
inherent in media representations and
that are inherent in the way we perceive
this great civilization but i think that
is in essence the problem of Russell
Russia is that he sees this Great
Western civilization in all of his
freedom and as an artist he says
as many artists say there's nothing
greater as we understand the
Constitution the First Amendment of the
Constitution the Bill of Rights says
Congress shall make no law that touches
our freedom of expression so being a man
of multiple identities living in two
worlds he chooses the world that allows
him or that he sees and perceives to be
the most highly evolved world and
civilization and I think he was remiss
in really understanding what we call the
old world traditions it's long so when I
think of this idea and his notion of
freedom of speech that we cherish so
much you know the history better than I
know the West
has given us the impression that freedom
and freedom of speech is something that
we cherish and something that is
absolute but we know that they are some
issues surrounding certain aspects of
freedom of speech that do not in fact
represent freedom of speech that other
institutional facilities inhibit
people's ability to freely express
themselves this is one the arguments
that animas really makes when he talks
and critiques salman rushdie's work and
talks about the problem around freedom
of speech in the Western world but i'm
not going to spin this brief time
contrasting and comparing the East in
the West I just want us to look at some
issues that I favor critical and help us
walk through some understanding around
our practices our way of life our
worldview the aspect of freedom of
speech has always been cherished in
Islamic tradition now i want to say oh
they look at me as a well what do you
don't know look at me so that was saying
all these other towers and his dictators
and even some countries in it un
reported the UN report or at the United
Nations on freedom of religion religious
belief gave the Muslim countries the
worst smart terms of freedoms of
religious expressions that although the
media is controlled by this faith in the
state sensores New York I mean the
census Time magazine in Newsweek and
there's just no real freedom of
expression in these Muslim countries I'm
not going to defend i don't have to
defend governments because i'm basically
an intellectual so I don't take a
position to have to defend governments I
love American I have problems with our
government
so I critique government's so it is
important to understand when I'm talking
about Islam I'm talking about Islam I'm
not talking about individual governments
in particular places I'm really talking
about Islam and their ideals or what we
are supposed to be practicing for Islam
has always promoted and promulgated the
idea of the notion that individual human
beings have freedom to express
themselves now this is the creator of
the universe in Islam a loss of a
nautilus says
oh do ela sabe leer abeka bill hikmah
will now isn't it has hella call to the
way of your lord with wisdom and goodly
teachings and argue with them in the
best of ways now what is important about
this ayah there are so many eyes that I
can talk about in the Quran verse in the
Quran to talk about I substantiate and
support this idea of the freedom of
expression but I think I want you to
understand the concept the concept is
that the creator of the universe is
saying to a prophet messenger then you
are supposed to Muhammad go and invite
the people to the way of one God with
goodly teaches with jicama wisdom and
goodly teaching so the creator of the
universe is engaging in a dialogical
relationship with human beings he is not
saying and he has the power and the
authority to say whole or say couldn't
fire Cohen be and it is but a loss of
another hour the creator of the universe
is saying this he is saying let it grow
heavy d there's no compulsion in
religion i have the power to make all of
you believers but i give you free will
that i have all authority but have
authorized you to express a freedom of
choice to choose whether or not you even
believe in me so that is the epitome of
the notion of free freedom of expression
freedom of belief and friendly the
ability to choose your own to choose
what not you want to be an atheist you
have the choice so when you see any
Muslims say that we are going to try to
force anybody to be a Muslim and will
you find some
some document this is the Muslims
converting the people through force and
you say well if there were any Muslims
who convert the people through force
wherever they were and probably their
work because you know that the destiny
these human beings they may have forced
somebody with a night to say just recite
these words but these people did not
convert because of force in their heart
so you say what Islam did not and Allah
did not force anybody the creative
universe did not force anybody to become
a Muslim or to embrace the belief in him
because the essence is you have to have
the freedom of will to choose so there's
a dialogic between the creative universe
his prophet and the human beings I make
Muslim I guide the people's hearts you
can't force them to be Muslim your
obligation is only as a prophet as was
all of the other prophets beginning with
Adam to invite people to this way to
introduce them to the creator of the
universe is and thereafter they make a
choice and if they decide not to then
that's their choice you respect them
then not in any way becomes becoming
second-class citizen because they have
not embraced Islam they're not become
second-class citizens citizens or less
than human beings because they have
refused to embrace what I embrace they
have made that choice in their freedom
because the creator gave them that
choice not me so I can't misrepresent
what the creator's order is and that is
everyone has the ability
to make that choice now along with the
dialogic is a dialectic and that is the
argument so Allah says argue with them
in the best of ways he is saying now we
are to debate we are to engage each
other and as you understand it civil
society and civilization we engage with
it which is with each other with the
levels of civility that is respectful
and that is decent as well law says
we'll hit my warm owie that it has an ax
now a little hustle I mean you cannot
insult people you can't demonize people
you can't belittle people you can't you
can't treat people in any way that
demeans because that is not the way that
along wants to introduce or that you
represent your Creator because you are a
representative of him on this earth
khalifatul are the representative on
this earth so you have an obligation as
an ambassador to represent him and you
will be called back and you will lose
your portfolio if you don't do it the
way he has ordained you do
the tradition of Islam in the early
period was a tradition that allowed for
freedom of expression freedom of
religious belief and the ability the
freedom to articulate not only to
express your belief to practice your
belief but to we would articulate that
belief and to tell others about it now
why was telling others the most
important thing in Islam all over all of
the scholars or llamaste your primary
obligation as a Muslim is tomato soup
spread a mess of Islam not to establish
an Islamic state not just have Islamic
Society your obligation is like the
allegation of the prophet and that is to
invite people to the way of your Lord to
save them from this sins in the evil of
society to bring them into the
opportunity to gain paradise and eternal
life so why is this idea of the
articulation so important it is
important because it like the preceding
messages head Amen deck from the Creator
as were the religions are preceded as
you may understand or know that Islam
primarily represents the final
revelation of God's give guidance to the
human family that it began with Adam and
we go to the succession of the prophets
and the messages for Moses from Abraham
from Abraham Moses Jesus
we are you understand we respect and
revere Jesus as being a beloved prophet
of Allah and to the final prophet which
was Muhammad in all of religious books
so part of the new message and you
understand why it's so critical that
Muslims have the freedom to express
themselves is that the Muslims are
saying we have and God has given us the
final message to give to you you have
preceding messages we have the final
what to give it to you there's not make
us the chosen people it makes us people
that are representing khalifatul odd
representing God on this earth and we
continue the message in a responsibility
of delivering a message so in the early
period of Islam unique laila for the
period of the rashi do moon first the
prophet used to say the people would
reveal the Prophet himself and say
you're not a problem but exceptions been
a problem in the Quran would say engage
them discuss them see if they can bring
something better than this Quran can
they bring something better can they
write something better than this court
and everything so Allah is involved in a
dialogical process with the people and
the Hejaz at that period the people in
my friend that period in as part of a
dialogical process they're saying no we
reject is prove it to us the Prophet is
saying and argue with them in the best
of ways and many of them embracing the
Solomon / rejecting yourself right
so after the death of the Prophet and
during the time of the khilafah DK lives
there could be no other example of the
freedom of expression that when Omar in
a llama and the second Calif was
approached by a woman who said to him
who reprimanded him in public yeah a
little young because he had said that
the women it would it would be better
for their women to pray in their home
because when the problem was the light
women pray in the mosque and he in his
intention to try to make sure because he
knew the definite profit would create a
sort of different social dynamic in
society that he would even be tempted on
a level that they weren't there may not
be able to really withstand and it's
different when a prophet is present so
he was out of protection saying when
it's best to separate the sexes
learnership pppp the woman said yeah I'm
on this is not what the prophet shall
also have said this is something you're
saying and we rejected one of the
aqueous I mean this is this is the
speaking truth to power this is the kata
the great caliph of Islam a woman saying
we're correcting you when abu bakr red
lion took the pledge of being the
Khalifa the Muslim said as long as you
follow Allah so Allah and His Prophet we
will follow you as soon as you don't
with clinically and finally when Nalu
rely on engage with what we call in
Islam the bohot the rebels the horrid
i'ts who rejected his decision in terms
of who was deleted
should be in the community the rebels
used to come to the mosque and insult
Ali publicly who's a halifa threatened
in a command you say should we stop them
who said no don't bother his actions in
terms of how you deal with people that
were rebels against the states quote
unquote is what is this substance and
the lessons of in the books of Islamic
law and felt Islamic rules and
regulations because he wrote that I mean
that his example was the model which
Muslims are dealing with each other when
they are rebels and when I decide and as
Islam evolved from umayyad periods i
think 661 to 750 there was a probable
malawi an issue of state-sponsored
problematic surround suppressing dissent
then after umayyads took over 770 up to
12 13th century the islamic civilization
flourished open society open issues
questions debates among the scholars
difference of opinions and always
finally they all mmos learners scholars
have always been within the context of
islamic civilization society part of the
civil society that corrected and that
was a corrective for the rulers and the
leaders there on a man or the people
whether were the leaders that the people
listen to even over the rulers and that
was that countervailing balance that
existed in Islamic society that is
different from civil society in the
Western world but nonetheless a critical
example of what civil society and how
civil society operated and how power and
structures operated within the Islamic
polity and it is important for us to
understand that no we do not have to
look at the work of the optic of the
Western way we have to be very very
careful in trying to impose a Western
view on how others should conduct their
lives and they are they
when people have been operating for
thousands and we have to get to the
point finally where we are in a where we
at a level where we appreciate others
contributions we've got to get to in
this country in this critical period
that we live in these are some of the
worst of times these are some of the
best of times that they afford us an
opportunity to take advantage Reed
conceptualizing how we deal with each
other moving beyond notions of essential
eyes race moving beyond the notion of
essential eyes notions of belief systems
and religions but align for each other
to respect one another through knowing
each other and learning about each other
for it is important that we understand
there clearly that we live the america
america has change it will never be the
same we live in society where we have
more Muslim from different countries and
we have in any Muslim country this is a
multi religious and pro religious
society and it's going to always be
Islam is growing and the report to be
the festival religion in America so we
have to work together to make sure that
we can collaborate and make this Society
of Great Great Society greater than
today
for who can even calculate the
contributions that the Muslims have made
six to eight million in this country who
work who are professionals who
contribute money and resources and taxes
in this country will give money to their
relatives abroad who can calculate who
can quantify the contributions that
Islam has made and muscles of mater's
decided we just are actually bringing in
groups of people who believe in moral
and ethical teachings of the Koran and
we cannot demon as a whole group of
people predicated on the actions of a
few limited french people who are in no
way really represent what islam really
teaches so let us not think about the
Islamic committee but and some painted
with a broad brush that it is a
monolithic community where all people
are the same they all believe in the
same and they all anti-american they all
anti-democratic and they all terrorists
and I'm sure you don't believe that but
we have a long way to go but we can get
there if we work together thank you very
much
before we have one final presentation
before we open the floor up for any
questions or discussion and so far we
heard the activism of the analysis than
the natural and delta T analysis now I
just want to read to use the official
statement on Midnight's Children itself
the play of when the Muslim religious
leadership here in the city was
contacted by the school of the oxen
Apollo Theater we were asked to issue a
statement on the play itself we
requested and were granted copies of the
script of the play we have about half a
dozen copies which we spread out amongst
the committee who reviewed them and the
result of was this statement which I
read to you and they were open field and
this is New York City Muslim leadership
official statement on the plane
Midnight's Children we the Islamic
Leadership Council of modernist ashura
of New York in conjunction with the Mars
Consultative Council of Power which is
called the Harlem sure having consulted
with the leadership of both the Muslim
alliance in north america and the
Islamic circle of north america
as well as other colleagues in the
Muslim community do hereby declare the
following with regards to the play
Midnight's Children scheduled to open at
the Apollo Theater in mid-march and a
positive number one we express our
appreciation to Columbia University
President Lee Bollinger and the board of
directors of the Apollo Theater for the
opportunity to express our religious
concerns about the play years ago when
Salman Rushdie's book Satanic Verses was
published it was filled with blasphemous
imagery depictions and thinly veiled
references that assaulted the most
sacred persons of the religion of Islam
just deeply offended muslims throughout
the world when the late ayatollah
ayatollah khomeini issued a fatwa which
is a judicial opinion of ruling
according to islamic law calling for mr.
Rushdie's death most non-muslims and
some of their Muslim intellectual
colonies responded to what they declared
to be an assault upon the human right to
freedom of speech and x
mr. woody himself declared on American
public television that his object was to
secularize all of Islam in the quote in
spite of the global presence of over a
billion Muslims mr. Rushdie himself was
never harmed this can be attributed to
the balanced moderate assessment of the
situation by mainstream worldwide Muslim
by the mainstream worldwide Muslim
community however the religious
sentiments of the same Muslims and those
who sympathize with them based upon
similar experiences in their own face
were subsequently disregarded swept
aside in the arm suing public discourse
at the same time or at that time muslim
concerns focus not only upon the
immediate offense but the door we
believed mr. Rushdie to be opening on to
more such attacks upon Islam's sacred
persons and beliefs now in the 21st
century this has proven true as American
evangelical Christian leaders in
particular have mounted a verbal assault
upon the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him and Muslims over the past two years
their slanderous public statements have
impugn the character of an entire
worldwide faith community and its most
revered person in spite of this both the
modhri's ashura and Harlem sure
chose to look at the play Midnight's
Children for its own merits and demerits
focusing not so much upon its political
statements but rather this religious
ones subtle or obvious to that end
having where'd the please script we were
pleased to see that there was no
sacrilege committed in it against the
religion of Islam or a secret beliefs or
persons comparable or even close to that
of this iconic verses and let me just
point out here that in actuality
Midnight's Children was written before
the Satanic Verses and it had just come
there were early efforts made to all
convert it into a play and really just
now all these years later the Royal
Shakespeare Company was able to put
together our just saw production mr.
Rushdie obviously has his own personal
contempt for Islamic etiquettes this is
exhibited by his lampooning of hijab
which is an aspect of the religions
social practices which include God of
social interaction between men and women
modest covering of a woman's physical
person in public etc which occurs in the
plains first part and just some really
heavy sack I of going on a man takes his
has an adult daughter who is ill and he
takes his daughter to be examined by a
doctor the doctor
turns out to be a man so they have a you
see on stage a huge sheet with a big
hole in and the doctor asked the father
world what does that hold for he says
well whichever part of my body you want
to examine she was going to stick it in
that hole so first you know she sticks
out an arm he feels wrong who pulls the
arm bet did it elbow then aggress then a
buttock you know that debt that sort of
thing this again you know now pointing
the Islamic social standard nonetheless
his personal feelings on his own and he
has a right to them however at least in
this work mr. rashmi seems more
interested in satirizing the socio
political history of the Indian
subcontinent than risking a repeated
affront towards Muslims Americans
because of the ninja of our popular
culture Americans may take such satire
and Christ what Midnight's Children runs
the risk of inflaming misunderstanding
between the two sub-continental
communities of Muslims and Hindus and
therefore has religious leaders we
recognize that humanity is living in
tents times that demand sensitivity and
respect for the religious beliefs and
sentiments of others it is our hope that
the best handling of the dynamics
surrounding this production of ms
children will model the sensitivity and
cooperation needed by all of us not only
in the world of art and literature but
as neighbors in a global village and
this concludes the reading of the
official statement of the Medusa Shora
and now we'd be pleased to open the
floor in case there any questions or
comments that any of you would like to
share thank you feel free technical
yes sir
can it can everyone hear helmet does he
need to come to the mic maybe if you
just speak a little louder that would be
good or if you want here's a mic right
here yeah
I just wanted to make one comment
without little play first I'd like to
say that I recently over the last few
months especially have learned quite a
bit about history I am really astonished
sort of what I didn't
and so I'd like to see
for the tradition and in truth I believe
that I mean I believe that you have the
same fundamental beliefs at the core of
the war
modern machine even in
I think that almost every major religion
and so what I would
it was really something to see
and so I guess my suggestions that in my
experience and I think this is something
that that perhaps
conveyancer if there's not really one
Hinduism there's not one song there's
not one Christianity but rather you know
each person in some sense has his own
chart belief or something like this to
each individual interprets what that
person learns and contains is only it so
in a sense there's this tremendous
diversity of belief across India
from what I know that many scholars
argue that that couldn't really call
India you know a single country a
country possessing of a single culture
that is a diverse land and then it would
be incorrectly and obviously culture but
then would be incorrect to say that it's
Elaine prequels
this tremendous variety and tremendous
diversity
these two or maybe three fundamentally
distinct culture
and so without minimizing the your
concerns for the way the American sort
of the populace corrected receive
Islamic culture I guess some
whether it was done well but but I at
least for me having written in the
embryo having process book that was
really in what sense that I got any sort
of attack on Islam although I am I don't
disagree
thank you thank you very much and and
I'm sorry did you say that you witnessed
set yourself in India yeah uh-huh great
fantastic thank you very much anyone
else like to share comment or a question
may I make a comment on your comment the
the reason that it's because the source
is one that's gondal Mike in our
traditions we are told that Prophet
Muhammad was told told us that in
addition to the 25 names that appear in
the holy book of alcohol an of prophets
and messengers 25 names that God
Almighty had sent throughout history
more than 124,000 messengers before and
therefore to convey that same message
and so whether it's Buddhism or Hinduism
or the Western or all these other old
faith groups I believe did indeed
receive the same message but as a result
of time
people have added subtracted change to
fit the circumstance of their time and
so the similarity then is there because
this horse is indeed one and that's God
Almighty the weather was mentioning
about the word fatwa of how many against
Ruth t well we should remember that Iran
is one of 56 Muslim countries and was
only Iran that passed that edict whereas
the other 55 did not and so it should
not be taken as representing all the
Muslim world because Muslim world is
really made up of many many different
groups and concerning the idea of the
spread of Islam by the sword which many
orientalists have perpetrated if it was
by the sword muslims ruled spain for 800
years would you think if it was by the
sword
Catholicism would have remained in Spain
after eight hundred years the same thing
goes for Muslims ruling India for 700
years you think it was by the short
Hinduism would have remained as is on
the country because as the brother said
that islam teaches and God says let it
cry 15 there must be no compulsion in
religion and that is basic I think to
understand and in America Islam is the
fastest growing community where is the
sword just as I like you to share i
think we've got about five minutes i
wanted to share with you i mentioned
earlier that this past friday morning
there was a forum at the Apollo Theater
and it was a community forum as the I
happen to be you know one of the people
that has attended a few different
meetings about this play and out my
favorite description of it actually came
from a local police precinct commander
expect the higdon over at the 28th
precinct and we were in a meeting and he
said well he said do I understand
correctly that the train left the
station and was headed this way before
anyone told you that it it was going to
be arriving and and everybody said well
kind of yes so as the University and the
apollo theater itself began to then kind
of talk around in the community trying
to get a sense of the sentiment in the
community about this coming
production there was enough energy
around the subject that they decided the
Apollo decided to pull together
community forum and so there was a panel
of people that included a director one
of the directors from Midnight's
Children the director of a local group
called the Harlem arts alliance board
member from the Apollo Theater mr Bruce
Ferguson who is the Dean over it
Columbia School of the Arts a
representative of the Harlem business
community mr. Lloyd Williams who was the
head of the column Chamber of Commerce
and myself representing the community
and particularly the Muslim community
and their discussion really became in a
very positive way very lively and very I
believe enlightening for particularly
for the people from the Royal
Shakespeare Company as well as from the
University as well as from the Apollo
Theater the point was made for instance
that if mr. Rushdie had been an author
who wrote racially controversial
material that all parties involved would
have been a lot more cautious and a lot
more solicitous of sentiment then they
were but because it's religion you know
our religion takes second place the race
in America so there wasn't that great
are concerned about that someone the
freedom of speech issue came up and one
of the businessmen wanted the Harlem
businessmen comment
that in Harlem itself that the people of
Harlem always very mindful of a double
standard when it comes to the issue is
concerning freedom of speech and he used
as an example of this very controversial
rally that took place in Harlem doing
the Giuliani administration that was
called the million youth launch and
there was this tremendous outpouring of
people to hear this radical and
controversial keynote speaker the police
department responded to the crowd by
adapting what has now become star
balloons procedure which is the pin in
crowds hell I was out there helicopters
you know buzzing the crowd as the
controversial keynote speaker began to
speech the police were looking at their
watches like this and then at exactly
the hour of expiration of the permit cut
the power off the yank you know so so he
was making the point this really isn't
isn't a good representation of the
standard of freedom of speech it was an
african-american artist who made a
controversial painting that was hanging
in i think it was in the Museum of
Modern Art in Brooklyn Brooklyn Museum
of Art and Mayor Giuliani threatened to
cut off the funding this doesn't be
speak very well to freedom of speech and
people were just making these points
people on the panel people in the
audience the point was made that column
itself and I like to always remind us
I was passing by Columbia University the
other day and write those of you who are
familiar with the University there's a
building called Earl hall and right
outside of Earl hall on the wall on the
Broadway there's a plaque that's
committed commemorating General George
Washington's leadership in the Battle of
Harlem heights so I intended tell
president Bollinger that if he wants to
increase the good relations between the
University and column that he could
start by saying well the university is
in halle lights that's posted all upper
west side morningside hi all of these
other names the Cape they came later but
column itself has a very large and
ever-expanding Muslim community most of
the Muslims in Harlem are Africans and
african-americans or maybe 15 years ago
there were 33 mosques in Hong and one of
the mosque was barely open now they're 9
mas in Harlem and the majority of the
Muslims as I said African and
african-american over the past decade
there's been a tremendous of migration
of West African Muslims from the cine
Gambian region of Africa into column so
much so that entire sections of
a good best example is the 116 Street
corridor which stretches from maybe Park
Park Avenue all the way over to eighth
Avenue if you go and look at we call it
little Africa it because it's just every
store on that strip is particularly
between linux and eight is owned by
either an african or an african american
muslim but also the south asian muslims
in harlem who work we have stores they
are Arab Muslims and I can judge just
buy my own congregation I remember very
clearly at one time that everyone who
worshipped at the mosque of Islamic
Brotherhood where I am a man were all
either african-americans or Spanish
speaking specifically Porto Rican
Muslims now and in the majority is still
that way but when I come out on friday
to give the to give discernment when I
look out I see primarily African
Americans but I also see several
Africans I'll see the Muslims in New
York City who are Spanish speaking or no
longer just Porto Ricans there's a lot
of them are Dominican for instance as
well as Arabs and south south asians and
we're really our mosque is in south
central harlem so i just kind of made
the point to all parties involved that
you know in the 21st century if we're
going to try to model the best of the
global village that when
institutions like the Apollo or Columbia
University want to bring four million
dollar productions into the hood and as
one of one of the people in the audience
was Barbara and Chia who is the director
of the oldest extant artistic and
cultural institution in Harlem called
national black theater they've been
around about 35 years or so and she made
the point that she and she made it very
dramatic when she pulled out the first
article that he saw in that she had seen
in the New York Times trumpeting this
cooperation between the Royal
Shakespeare Company and Columbia
University in there Paulo in this four
million dollar production that's going
to be in Harlem I think a total of ten
days and she made the point that all of
the community theatre groups in Harlem
could run for a few years with the
productions were four million dollars
and no one had bothered to ask them you
know to me hey how do we get in on some
of this cuz we're here all year round so
I just wanted to share that were you
going to say something say
the increasing diversity of Muslim
community in Holland a few years and the
moderation of the official statement of
a yes concerning the production in
Holland I wonder to what extent the
official statement is indeed
representative of the broader feeling in
my that's an excellent question up two
things number one and I think this is
very revealing I would say most people
in Harlem period don't even know the
place is there I'm here Midnight's
Children Act is that was it sorry about
black people in India note that that's
on one hand number two I will say to you
very honestly that the play of actually
there are only two productions in
America a couple about a week ago week
we can have it was at the University of
Michigan where president Bollinger has
come has come from and this Apollo
production I know for a fact that Muslim
leaders and activists were concerned
about not if I can use this term
repeating the same mistake twice you
know looking but you know they always
say hindsight is 2020 and so I know a
lot of the leaders and activists felt
that of kind of just given open vent to
the visceral emotions that were
generated by satanic verses that
strategically that kind of backfire
against us because people really weren't
listening to our pain as
former president you know I feel your
pain if people weren't feeling the pain
they were responding to the visceral
reaction which when you take it mixing
in with not really knowing that much
about Islam anyway it created a very bad
PR so many of the Muslim leaders said
well no less really glad about way we're
going to look at this we're going to
call a shovel and shovel spade a spade
if it's really offensive we're going to
say that if it's not we're going to say
that too so that the as I told the
people at the Apollo the problem is not
the mainstream Muslim community you know
I took the problem is then the
extremists in the Muslim community and
the extremists in any community
professor alex lau said the muslim
community is not a monolithic community
and extremists they they're not the ones
in the leadership of the Harlem
shore or the mother New York modulus
ashore so right now at the Apollo they
are in fact they have in fact
implemented extraordinary security
measures x I mean I've been going to the
Apollo since I was a youngster I've
never seen such a you know and but again
I think that the fact that mr. Rushdie
is still walking around I saw mr.
Rushdie on Fifth Avenue or this past
August my wife and I we spent a nice
summer day we went to the the Islamic
art exhibit at the metropolitan museum
of art and after we had come out of the
art we standing on the subway who pulls
up into them over Salman Rushdie and he
gets out with
maybe at best two of his you know
intellectual friends and I mean I
recognize them so it fits you know I did
wonder if the pot law was still you know
how much could you get for smacking them
upside the head but yes ma'am go right
here yes
well that's a real hard place it all
depends on the media
in
and
all Muslims active in interfaith work
and relations please raise your right
hand they look around please that oil
gauge that puppy with we're all very
busy you know I would say if I may I
would say the answer to your question
number one is yes the reason being and I
think there are two reasons for that
number one so you have to understand
that this Muslim American population
that at least upwards of two million of
them really offers a three million are
people born and raised in America these
are not immigrants there are about two
million African American Muslims and
then there are young people who are the
children of Muslim immigrants who've
been born and raised in America who
don't know any other country other than
America and considered himself to be
American and their understanding and
expression of what it means to be a
Muslim is very American and it's very
you know moderate as a young lady told
me her name is Hana siddiqui I met her
parents are from Pakistan and when I
first met her she introduced herself as
the first Muslim woman to have a hip hop
radio show on the campus of UCLA this
hit this this ashley described himself
you know so yeah I think so and in Islam
is spreading so rapidly I mean you'd be
hard-pressed to find
don't have a Muslim somewhere in their
family now I mean I mean amongst you
know Americans of African descent
European descent spanish-speaking etc so
I think so what one of the real problems
and and there is friction now we will
really you know since we're talking
frankly there is friction in the Muslim
community and the friction is between
those who would give court and Islam
that a Muslim attitude I won't say in
Islam those who would import of Muslim
attitude from a part of the world is
very different than what's going on here
visa vie those of us who you know are
rooted in this particular environment
but as I recall last sep tember there
was an article in The New York Times
that said that if the Saudi Arabian
government admitted that they had been
really trying for some time to influence
islamic development in america and it
just hasn't been working because it this
is not the environment i mean i'm an
african-american I
about a year year and a half ago I
officiated at a funeral for Muslim who
had died everyone in the funeral you
know people that came was either Muslim
or Christian or a Jew and they were all
african-americans the Jews were
african-american so what I was talking
in something this so by immigrant
friends I've saved in LA I top that one
you know what you know where else in the
world are you going to get that kind of
natural diverse mix so there you have
yes sir way in the back
professor about my situation for the
image of Islam in America and in the
world and much to my surprise the
statistics state that more people in
America know about Islam more after 911
they did before nine eleven what has
happened is that American people first
of all had no reason to know anything
about Islam before nine eleven and now
as a result of the conflict and the
dastardly deeds of human beings God has
turned it into something where people
like in I want to be want to be informed
so now even and I looked at and I
thought about there was having a Middle
East war and all of these succession of
events we have to accept the fact that
and this is also part of what inflamed
the sentiments around southern rusty is
that there were some arrested the play
was I think I mean the book as far as
literary critics say wasn't it wasn't an
extraordinary piece of literature even
hey but the point is that and I think
he's a good writer the point is the
Muslims look at that is being part of a
Western project where it can contribute
to the demonization of Islam he was
rewarded he was celebrated for his
position and by much of the Western
world and it was part and parcel of a
sequence of events that took place
beginning with the breakup of the soviet
russia and
George Bush saying after then it was
heaven CIA that the next contending
power would be Aslam Islamic threat so
we had a succession of events happening
in the media of a process of
demonization as you know what happens in
political because of the politics often
determine what plays out in popular
culture even even in public discourse
because of perceived strategic national
interests in terms of governmental
officials that find it expedient to
create and cast images of peoples and
countries to serve what they would say
to be strategic national interests and
preserve and protect those interests so
you think about it from that perspective
you say well the Muslims are looking at
the sermon rosianna that being just
another process by which the Muslims can
be associated with people who are less
than human beings so now that the
American people who are very smart who
are in my estimation they're caring and
peace-loving people once they
investigate Islam it's like what you
know us to know us is to love us because
once you know and learn something about
Islam is that what this is all together
different than what I thought about and
if you think about the institutions for
example we're developing finally a
Religious Studies department at medgar
evers college part of CUNY because in
most of the college universities there's
no real teaching about Islam and some of
the top 10 universities you have Islamic
studies and I'm graduate Ohio but for
the most part in grade school and high
school textbooks there's a lot of work
needs to be done and clarifying the
misconceptions and really articulating
what Islam really stands for even my
students in college you know nothing
about Islam to even autospell a rock
they don't know anything about anything
has do the Middle East or the Islamic
world and the critical role that the
Islamic world has played in world
history I mean going back as far as they
did
the 7th century so now that I am in a
position to teach them something about
the history within the context of just
explaining and now not professor the
president of ecology as well you can no
longer negate or neglect the reality
that one-fifth of the world's population
are Muslims so you just cannot be
ignorant about one-fifth of the world's
population it sits on most of the of the
natural resources of the world religion
is sixty-five percent of the people in
Africa practice and none of that now
coming into conflict so now for the
issue of conflict mediation and
peacebuilding people who are in
international relations have to
understand something about Islam and
Muslims and it was indicative of the
fact that we talked about the State
Department ride to find people that was
even fluent in Arabic so they didn't
understand what was going on see I ended
try to recruit people to you didn't
because in have enough people have
understood stood anyway so now to your
question I think that we are just and
that's why this one I say this is the
best of times an opportunity it provides
an opportunity for us to be to accept
the fact that America is applauded I
never improved plural religious Proulx
ethnic multi-religious multi-ethnic
place and now we have to develop a
nomenclature a language then navigate
through their multiplicity and develop a
lexicon of how we able to talk to each
other that's a challenge it's not here
yet but for those who see the vision who
want this to be the best that it can be
then we have a tremendous responsibility
and a great opportunity I'm very
optimistic let's take two last comments
my comment was all relating to what
professors just in sankt as anonymous of
different among my acquaintances and I'm
well beyond the college-age friends and
I are reading a lot more about Islam
learning
pagans many courses on that was great
enough to travel to this is after nine
eleven travel to Mali and Senegal no
real experience to experience their
whole culture but to Islamic countries
to be there during the celebration of
the Abraham celebration that's great but
there's a lot of now I'm not
representative perhaps but there's a lot
intellectual interest so it's a tough
time it's a terrible time nervous or
scared the reaction that could hurt the
Muslim community from from a water yes
community I worried about that innaloo
the discrimination that may occur but
there's also a great deal of interest I
just want to say that hopefully their
warp about 250,000 people
demonstrated on that drink and now I
almost didn't go because story yeah
that's right absolutely thank you you
can't rise and we'll take a final
comment the reason I said it depends on
the media because unfortunately excuse
me brother garcia you were director of
communications media person he's a video
that's my point because unfortunately
the media loves sensationalism and does
not go into deep
what presentation of what our
communities will about and there is a
wall of ignorance and there is some
prejudice and some bigotry that we have
to face there is double standard now
when Timothy McVeigh or the irish
republican army sends explosions into
protestant london the me imagine if
McVeigh was a Muslim what would the
media say what if the Irish were Muslims
what would the media say so there is a
double standard terrorism has no
religion because no religion teaches
terrorism so to attribute Islamic
terrorism is a no starting because there
is no Christian terrorism there is no
jewish terror terrorism is done by human
beings who claim to be part of this or
this or that and so we have to also be
very careful in some definitions the
media gives itself to afford define the
meaning of jihad for example
if I asked my American friends here what
does she had mean what have you heard
every says what holy war holy war now we
all know that the only primary source of
Islamic education knowledge is the holy
book of al-quran now I challenge all the
media to open the book al-quran and show
me where jihad says is holy war these
two words do not exist in the only
primary source of Islamic knowledge and
teaching I'll collab therefore we have
to be very careful when we read a
translation because you had is not what
you are jihad has several aspects
controlling the evil within oneself is
the big jihad but defending your home
and a religion if attacked in a
defensive manner that is jihad raising
children in York is one of the big
gesture so these are another
misrepresentation comes in the media is
that Muslim women are oppressed
in Muslim countries and all that's why
the foursome Judaism now if wisdom women
are oppressed why is it that in
Bangladesh Indonesia Pakistan and Turkey
already had or have now a woman who is a
prime minister of the old country I mean
when would progressive civilized America
at least a vice president who is a woman
I mean let's think about it but the
media is playing a big role in
dehumanizing as Miss representing us
because they have not all of them that's
Leslie be honest and fair but they are
media that have an act a political axe
to grind against its time because of
Middle East problems because of listener
that's not the time for discussion but
there is such a thing and we have to be
very careful to read between the line
and make sure that it's going to take
time you're going to take interfaith
dialogue it's going to take us having a
medium to speak through we don't have a
Muslim media representation here that's
what I call upon all my young Muslim
colleagues and say whenever I go and
sleep it
media my friend you know we were taught
that this is a great country because
based on three separation of power they
have the release ative the judicial and
the administer but people forget the
fourth institution which is the medium
and in the third world it is set those
who control the army control the
government but in America it is those
who control the media control government
control many many things so I urge my
uncle e's I see some of your ear get
involved in the media study